[Música]
hoy en la entrevista de france 24
hablaremos sobre el futuro político de
ecuador a pocos meses de las elecciones
presidenciales y legislativas donde ex
presidentes y ex vicepresidentes se
enrutan en la carrera por los comicios
nos acompañan jacobo garcía sociólogo
paul y politólogo máster en estudios
latinoamericanos de la universidad de
salamanca y analista y consultor
especializado en investigaciones de
opinión pública y comportamiento
electoral gracias jacobo por estar con
nosotros y comienzo preguntándole en
febrero del 2000 21 ecuador tiene su
cita electoral en medio de la pandemia y
de un revuelo político por quien seguirá
en la presidencia como ha sido el uso
político de la crisis sanitaria
bueno muy buenos días y un gusto
encantado estar con ustedes bueno creo
que en la gestión de la pandemia ha sido
bastante deficiente y hablo a nivel
objetivo y a nivel subjetivo es decir a
nivel objetivo si vemos las cifras de
fallecidos de contagios y diferentes
episodios que han sucedido en estos
meses creo que ha dejado mucho que
desear y si vemos las cifras subjetivas
de opinión pública vemos a un gobierno
con unas cifras de credibilidad de
aceptación muy bajas bajísimas todos los
estudios lo señalan entre los gobiernos
con menor credibilidad de la región y
esto en parte si ya bien se venía
arrastrando de hace tiempo en parte es
por una gestión que se considera que ha
sido bastante deficiente
ya antes de la pandemia ecuador
enfrentado a una crisis económica que
tendrá que asumir quien llegue al cargo
en mayo del 2021 el oficialismo hoy
encabeza de lenin moreno está catalogado
como ustedes ya dijo de impopular y esto
tiene que ver mucho también con el
paquetazo que lanzó el presidente que
incluyó el fin de 40 años en ayudas en
los precios de las gasolinas y del
diesel se cobrará esto en las urnas
sí sin duda y de hecho estos fue un
punto de inflexión en esta baja
popularidad del gobierno recordemos que
esta medida de eliminar el subsidio a la
gasolina lo que conllevó fue una gran
movilización que digamos derivó en un
estallido social que paralizó al país
durante varios días y esto obviamente
generó un descontento que como decía yo
antes se sigue arrastrando hasta el día
de hoy entonces sin duda sin duda que
esto se va a ver reflejado en las urnas
porque además desde entonces la economía
no se ha recuperado y con la pandemia lo
que vemos es que al contrario la
economía va cada vez peor han aumentado
las cifras de desempleo de informalidad
y esto va a ser un gran factor en las
elecciones bueno y entonces qué va a
pasar por ejemplo con el ex presidente
rafael correa podría perseguir el
exmandatario una banca legislativa
recordemos que tiene una condena por
cohecho y además que es investigado en
otras 20 causas
bueno esto va a depender de varias cosas
en la primera razón es
tiene que haber una sentencia
ejecutoriada para que esto lo impida es
ser candidato
y esta sentencia está digamos en la
última fase en el último recurso que se
llama el recurso de casación entonces
hasta que no concluya esto por esa vía
no podemos decir que todavía no pudiera
ser candidato ok pero hay otro elemento
y es que en el reglamento del código en
la democracia del cine a la hora de
inscribir una candidatura se solicita
que el candidato esté presente
físicamente si es para binomio nacional
que esté presente en el país y si es
para asambleísta en este caso el
exterior que esté presente en el
consulado o embajada respectiva y aquí
es donde hay un problema porque hay
quien señala que podría presentarse la
fuerza pública del orden en este
consulado en este caso en bélgica que es
donde reside el ex presidente correa si
él quisiera ser candidato a asambleísta
y pudiera ser aprendido aunque aquí hay
una discusión en ecuador a nivel
jurídico y legal
esto se puede hacer o no se puede hacer
pero para cerrar la idea digamos que a
día de hoy es bastante complicado que él
pueda ser candidato alguna dignidad y en
caso de serlo lo más factible sería ser
asambleísta del exterior pero con el
problema que le comentaba yo antes bien
pues le agradecemos por sus impresiones
y nos queda en el tintero el caso del ex
presidente abdalá bucarám y quien fue
presidente de ecuador por seis meses
tras una destitución y que lanzó su
precandidatura de las presidenciales el
9 de agosto pero tres días después fue
detenido por presunta participación en
delitos de delincuencia organizada siga
con nosotros en france 24
tenemos más para ustedes